monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues nous retrouvons ce matin donc
Isabelle Falque Pierrotin
présidente de l'autorité nationale des
jeux que nous avions entendu en juin
2020 à l'occasion de sa nomination dans
le cadre de la procédure prévue à
l'article 13 de la Constitution
autrement dit pour sa nomination
effectivement la régulation des jeux de
hasard et d'argent a fait l'objet d'une
actualité nourrie la création de l'auto
de la biodiversité sur le modèle du Loto
du patrimoine a été discuté en sciences
publiques
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023
le Sénat avait d'ailleurs vous le savez
voter à une large majorité sa
suppression avant qu'il ne soit rétabli
dans le texte final c'est pour vous dire
bien la Coupe du monde de football a
remis en avant la question de la
régulation des paris sportifs et de
l'addiction au jeu
ainsi à l'automne 2022 santé publique
France a pour la première fois lancé une
campagne de prévention visant
spécifiquement les paris sportifs enfin
il y a deux semaines le Parlement
européen a adopter une proposition
visant à mettre en place une étude dans
l'optique de mieux encadré les loot
boxes dans les jeux vidéo
face à tous ces enjeux cette audition à
vocation à faire un point d'actualité
sur l'ensemble des problématiques qui
entourent les jeux de hasard et d'argent
elle doit aussi permettre de débattre
des principes et des critères de la
régulation des jeux ainsi que de la
fiscalité qui leur est applicable la
privatisation de la Française des jeux
prévue par la loi pacte de 2019 a marqué
une étape importante sur ces questions
pouvez-vous nous expliquer quels ont été
les conséquences de cette privatisation
sur les pratiques du régulateur je vous
rappelle dans la précédente que cette
audition est retransmise en direct sur
le site internet du Sénat je vous laisse
tout de suite la parole
merci monsieur le Président bonjour à
tous
effectivement l'autorité nationale des
jeux après ce que trois ans nous aurons
3 ans au mois de juin donc c'est une
autorité qui est a été installée en juin
et qui est je dirais en charge de la
régulation d'un secteur qui est un
secteur
complexe complexe parce que
d'abord il croit très vite
le taux de croissance du PBJ dans les
trois dernières années est important et
surtout il est profondément hétérogène
profondément hétérogène puisque le
territoire de régulation de la NJ c'est
donc un PBJ d'environ 11 milliards
d'euros et des acteurs à réguler qui se
composent à la fois des 17 opérateurs en
concurrence des deux grands monopoles
PMI PMU FDJ dont la FDJ qui représente à
soi seul la moitié du chiffre d'affaires
du secteur
200 un peu plus de 200 casino un peu
plus de 200 hippodromes et des clubs de
jeux
et pour
caractériser l'offre l'offre elle-même
se répartit entre des paris sportifs des
paris hippiques de la loterie du poker
en ligne donc
vous voyez bien que nous agrégeons en
tant que régulateur un secteur qui est
un secteur en forte croissance et qui
est profondément hétérogène dans les
acteurs qui composent le dissecteur et
quand je dis en forte croissance il y a
deux moteurs principaux à cette
croissance d'une part le secteur en
ligne
qui représente maintenant 20% du chiffre
d'affaires du secteur et d'autre part
les paris sportifs qui dans les
dernières années ont effectivement cru à
un taux de croissance à un taux rapide
puisque par exemple en 2021 les paris
sportifs en ligne ont augmenté de 44%
sur l'année
c'est probablement un peu moins vrai en
2022 mais en tout cas c'est un levier de
croissance qui est très important alors
ce secteur effectivement on a créé par
la loi pacte un régulateur unique quel
est l'objet
l'office de ce régulateur et bien c'est
d'appliquer la politique de l'État et la
politique de l'État je vous la rappelle
parce que elle est importante à avoir en
tête c'est
limiter et encadrer l'offre et la
consommation de jeux
donc il y a bien un objectif de
limitation de l'offre et de la
consommation de jeu et puis les quatre
objectifs que doit respecter la
politique de l'État c'est prévenir le
jeu excessif assurer l'intégrité de
l'offre prévenir les activités
frauduleuses et lutter contre le
blanchiment et veiller à l'équilibre des
filières donc on voit que la régulation
elle doit
s'insérer dans l'objectif général de
l'État qui est le jeu d'argent et a
priori interdit sauf dérogation et cette
dérogation elle doit être strictement
contrôlée par le régulateur qui doit par
ailleurs veiller aux quatre objectifs de
la politique de l'État et j'insiste sur
la nécessité de bien avoir ceci en tête
parce que face à un marché qui est en
très forte croissance et dont l'acteur
principal en l'occurrence la FDJ est
également très forte croissance on voit
bien que on atteint quand même non pas
les limites de la régulation mais en
tout cas une complexité qui devra être
traitée par le régulateur alors
l'actualité l'actualité vous l'avez
mentionné monsieur le Président c'est
effectivement la Coupe du monde
peut-être un certain nombre de chiffres
sur cette Coupe du monde
au total
en ligne et en dur c'est à dire dans les
points de vente FDJ
on aura presque
un peu plus de 900 millions d'euros qui
ont été parié
c'est un record absolu en ligne on
éteint 600 millions d'euros qui ont été
parié et ce sont des performances qui
sont beaucoup plus importantes que la
dernière Coupe du Monde ou même l'euro
les
matchs sont des matchs
qui ont permis à l'équipe de France
d'aller évidemment jusqu'à la finale et
la finale contre l'Argentine a permis 80
millions d'euros pariés là aussi c'est
un record il y a encore à ce stade
jamais eu de matchs qui ont enregistré
autant de de Paris sur un seul match la
problématique qui était la nôtre c'est
d'essayer d'éviter que à l'occasion de
la Coupe du Monde se répète ce que nous
avions vu pendant l'Euro ce que nous
avions vu pendant l'Euro c'était une
surpression publicitaire extrêmement
forte qui avait ému nos concitoyens qui
avaient conduit un certain nombre
d'associations mais également de
parlementaires
de souhaiter que
la publicité sur les jeux d'argent soit
fortement restreinte en tout cas
il n'y avait pas eu à ce stade de
traduction législative ou réglementaire
mais je me sens bien que l'opinion
publique c'était mobilisée face à cette
surpression publicitaire et donc
l'autorité nationale des jeux a mis en
place à la suite de l'euro tout un
dispositif pour cantonner la pression
publicitaire à l'occasion de la Coupe du
monde de football ce dispositif ce sont
des guidelines des lignes directrices
des recommandations sur le type d'outils
publicitaires sur le niveau des
gratifications et elle le plan d'action
de la engie c'est notamment traduit par
la signature en novembre 2022 de quatre
chartes qui ont pu mobiliser à la fois
les opérateurs de jeux d'argent tous les
opérateurs de jeux d'argent qui ont
signé ces chartes mais également les
supports Radio Télévision affichage
numérique qui ont également acceptés
finalement de policer leur pratique
pour réduire la pression publique la
pression publicitaire en faveur du jeu
d'argent
la signature de ces quatre chartes et
certainement quelque chose d'assez
exceptionnel en termes de corégulation
puisque je crois qu'il n'y a pas
de secteurs qui est pu se mettre autour
de la table avec l'ensemble des supports
publicitaires pour se s'entendre sur une
limitation de la mobilisation de ces
supports
au profit de leur propre annonces donc
là je crois que ça témoigne d'une prise
de conscience et des annonceurs et des
supports sur le fait que le jeu d'argent
n'est pas un produit comme les autres et
donc il convient pour la publicité de la
cantonnée de l'encadrer peut-être d'une
façon plus vigoureuse que ce qui était
pratiqué auparavant alors est-ce que ça
suffit pour la Coupe du monde de
football
ce que l'on peut dire c'est que de façon
globale la tonalité des messages pendant
la coupe du monde de football à
est rentré dans le champ de ce que
permet le décret de novembre 2020 c'est
à dire que les messages les plus
dithyrambiques et les plus incitatifs à
l'acte de jouer de parier ont quasiment
disparu
concernant le le montant global de la
publicité
c'est un peu difficile aujourd'hui de
vous en donner les conclusions
définitives nous avons lancé une
opération de contrôle sur les quatre
principaux opérateurs et nous aurons
d'ici quelques semaines vraiment les
chiffres et les campagnes publicitaires
qui ont été lancées leurs évaluations et
donc on sera capable de savoir si le
cantonnement publicitaire que nous avons
demandé à effectivement été respecté
mais d'après les premières analyses des
équipes de la engie il semblerait que ça
soit bien le cas
cela étant il y a au moins deux
questions qui restent ouvertes et qui
nécessiteront que la NJ s'intéresse à
ces questions dans les semaines à venir
c'est le sponsoring
on sent bien que
face à l'encadrement plus énergique par
le régulateur de la publicité les
opérateurs jeux d'argent ont fait un pas
de côté et on mobilisait les ressources
du sponsoring notamment la sponsoring
démission sportive ce qui fait que il
n'est pas
anormal que pendant un match vous ayez
presque 12
spots publicitaires
sur un match en faveur des jeux d'argent
là où normalement nous nous avons
cantonné à trois
dans chaque tunnel publicitaire donc on
voit bien que le sponsoring est un moyen
de contourner un petit peu la les
contraintes sur la publicité stricto
sensu et puis il y a un deuxième
phénomène qui est celui des influenceurs
les influenceurs ont été énormément
mobilisés par les opérateurs jeux
d'argent en fin d'année et je dirais que
c'est une tendance de fond du secteur
ces influenceurs vous savez que le
gouvernement est en train à lancer une
concertation sur les influenceurs pour
voir comment on pouvait mieux encadrer
la pratique des influenceurs qui dans
certains cas à donner lieu presque à des
fraudes qui ont été d'ailleurs dénoncés
par un DGCCRF nous nous travaillons avec
la DGCCRF sur la question des
influenceurs et nous avons fait
d'ailleurs des recommandations au
gouvernement concernant les jeux
d'argent et les influenceurs mais il est
certain que c'est un c'est une nouvelle
technique publicitaire qui est très
mobilisée par le secteur et qui a besoin
peut-être d'être un peu plus encadré
donc
ce que nous pensons c'est que
la pression publicitaire qui est un
sujet majeur pour le régulateur la
pression publicitaire reste forte
les mesures que nous avons prises ont
permis de cantonner celle-ci
jusqu'à un certain point mais
nous réfléchissons à la nécessité le cas
échéant de compléter notre arsenal
réglementaire parce que les dernières
études que nous avons côté de venus de
l'OFDT montre qu'il y aurait une
augmentation du taux de prévalence
c'est-à-dire du pourcentage du
pourcentage de joueurs problématique et
donc il est important que l'on puisse
s'adapter à ses nouvelles
conclusion donc ça c'est la l'actualité
liée à la Coupe du Monde et puis nous
avons une actualité qui est liée à
l'évolution du secteur lui-même
je vous ai dit que le secteur était en
forte croissance qu'il avait deux
moteurs de croissance les paris sportifs
et le jeu en ligne il a surtout une
évolution liée aux nouvelles
technologies
les nouvelles technologies sont investis
massivement par les opérateurs de jeux
d'argent
partout
dans la mobilisation des outils
numériques
tous les opérateurs et les plus gros
d'entre eux en particulier
utilisent à fond toutes les technologies
de marketing numérique pour
toucher les individus personnalisés la
publicité avoir des publicités
interactives extrêmement fines et
extrêmement efficace donc ça je dirais
que ça concerne tous les opérateurs ce
que nous voyons également arriver c'est
les fameux crypto actifs
les crypto actifs ce sont ces NFT c'est
à dire ces objets numériques qui sont
qui font l'objet d'un enregistrement sur
la blockchain qui en soi ne sont pas
des jeux d'argent et de hasard en tant
que tel mais ces crypto actifs c'est NFT
font l'objet d'attribution dans le cadre
de compétition qui peuvent être des
compétitions
assimilables à des jeux d'argent et de
hasard vous avez probablement entendu
parler de la firme Sora de la société
sorar donc cette licorne française dont
nous sommes les uns les autres
extrêmement fiers que propose sera
propose
d'émettre des NFC
correspondant à des cartes à l'effigie
de joueurs de football
donc vous collectionnez ces cartes comme
auparavant on pouvait collectionner les
cartes
Yu-Gi-Oh pour les enfants ou Panini et
vous collectionnez ces cartes et ces
cartes
avec ces cartes vous pouvez constituer
des équipes ces cartes sont de vraies
cartes de football c'est-à-dire ce sont
des cartes à l'effigie de vrais
footballeurs
2 3 fois par semaine ce sont organisés
des compétitions d'équipe virtuelle
constituées par 5 cartes c'est à dire
que vous avez vos cartes et vous
constituez une équipe en tant que comme
si vous étiez un coach d'une équipe de
football et vous faites affronter votre
équipe avec d'autres
et ces compétitions de cartes vous font
gagner
des objets mais souvent de nouvelles
cartes et le prix de ces cartes la
valeur de ces cartes est indexée sur les
performances des vrais joueurs dans la
vie réelle
donc vous avez un marché de cartes qui
est pour partir indexée sur les
performances réelles des joueurs dans la
vraie vie dans les vraies compétitions
pour partie également indexée sur le
cours de l'éther la crypto monnaie
puisque en réalité tout ceci se paye on
était et donc le cours de l'éther
fait varier les revenus que vous tirez
des cartes
alors ça c'est l'expérience de Sora mais
il y en a bien d'autres
on a le même type
d'innovation dans le domaine hippique et
le PMU nous a présenté un projet qui
s'appelle le projet stable qui permet là
aussi d'avoir des cartes qui figurent
des chevaux pour le moment il n'y a pas
de compétition de ses chevaux il y a
juste comment dire une communauté qui se
crée autour des cartes de chevaux et de
la valeur de ces cartes qui va augmenter
et qui permet aux titulaire de ces
cartes dans le cas des chevaux de gagner
des points et progressivement d'avoir
une écurie qui prend plus de valeur que
une autre
aujourd'hui
il y a 2000
jeux web 3 comme on les appelle qui sont
disponibles en France
c'est un marché qui est un marché
émergent
il y a dans ces 2000 offres 2000 offres
des sociétés françaises mais toutes ces
offres ne sont pas reliées à une
activité de Paris hippique ou de paris
sportifs comme celle que je viens de
décrire il y a une partie des offres qui
sont des offres totalement décorrélés de
la vie réelle par exemple vous avez
un petit chien que vous achetez enfin
vous achetez un crypto actif qui
représente un petit chien vous élevez
votre petit chien
vous pouvez lui acheter un collier enfin
vous pouvez faire en sorte qu'il
prospère le plus possible et puis vous
allez croiser ce petit chien avec
d'autres et peut-être que vous aurez une
portée qui va prendre encore plus de
valeur que vous pourrez revendre
donc on voit que il y a toute une
économie du divertissement qui se met en
place à partir de ces nouveaux objets
numériques ces crypto actif
ces crypto actifs sont éminemment
addictifs
les premières études qui se font jour il
y a une étude australienne il y a une
étude britannique montre que le taux de
prévalence de ces activités qui croisent
le jeu d'argent le jeu vidéo la
spéculation financière
ce sont des offres qui sont au confins
de plusieurs registres dans le fond ce
sont des taux de prévalence qui sont
plutôt autour de 24
25%, là où le jeu d'argent en général
est plutôt à 6
donc on voit que on doit être
particulièrement vigilant sur
l'évolution de ces offres nous nous
souhaitons évidemment
accompagner l'innovation parce que il
est certain que ces évolutions
technologiques sont peut-être
l'avenir du Paris hippique et l'avenir
du paris sportif et d'ailleurs
c'est assez symptomatique que
les acteurs traditionnels de ce pari
hippique ou de ce pari sportif
s'intéressent à ces nouvelles offres et
veulent également en proposer mais il
faut évidemment que la régulation puisse
accompagner de façon réaliste ces
nouvelles offres et ne pas permettre
entre guillemets un siphonnage une
aspiration finalement
par ces nouvelles offres de toutes les
protections qui ont été mises en place
au bénéfice des joueurs depuis 2010 donc
ça c'est une actualité très importante
qui n'est pas simplement française dans
tous les pays européens ont s'intéresse
aux crypto actifs et aux nouvelles
questions de régulation que cela pose
nous travaillons avec nos homologues
avec les Suisses avec les Belges avec
les Britanniques pour voir si nous
pouvons adopter une position commune sur
ce sujet dernière élément de
d'actualité
l'activité de contrôle
de la NJ je la mentionne parce que
nous avons eu un certain nombre de
remarques
sur le fait que cette activité de
contrôle n'avait pas été déclenchée dès
la mise en place de la NJ en 2020
il est évident que lorsque la NJ a été
créée le dispositif
législatif et réglementaire était un
dispositif pour partie ancien mais quand
même pour partie assez nouveau pour
l'ensemble des acteurs c'était un
dispositif très complet qui se
traduisait par des obligations
récurrentes de présentation de documents
de plan d'action de stratégie
promotionnelle etc devant le régulateur
qui nécessitait d'être entièrement
expérimenté avant que de lancer des
contrôles donc nous avons dans un
premier temps privilégier l'approche
explicative et pédagogique avant de
pouvoir lancer des contrôles ces
contrôles ont été lancés à partir de
2022 et nous avons en 2022 pour la
première fois saisi la commission des
sanctions qui a été reconstituée
d'ailleurs puisque cette commission des
sanctions n'était pas opérationnelle en
2021 ces membres n'étant pas désignés
donc nous avons fait en sorte que cette
commission des sanctions puissent être
effectivement reconstitué et nous avons
transmis un certain nombre de dossiers à
la commission des sanctions des dossiers
relatifs au respect du TRJ taux de
retour joueur qui vous le savez pour le
paris sportif et 85 % évaluer
annuellement et
il y avait probablement un certain
nombre de petites comment dire
manquement par rapport au respect de ce
TRJ et le deuxième type de dossier que
nous avons
transmis à la commission des sanctions
sont des dossiers qui sont relatifs à
une nouvelle obligation et tout à fait
centrale des opérateurs de jeux d'argent
c'est l'obligation d'identifier et
d'accompagner les joueurs à risque
et donc nous avons pour la première fois
saisis la commission des sanctions de
manquement sur cette obligation nouvelle
2023 sera une année importante en termes
de contrôle puisque maintenant nous
considérons que le nouveau dispositif
législatif et réglementaire et connu que
nous avons assorti ce dispositif de
toute une série de boîte à outils de
bonnes pratiques diverses et que
maintenant ceux qui ne le respectent pas
n'ont pas véritablement de raison à le
faire et donc nous allons avoir une
politique de contrôle qui sera
vigoureuse en 2023
un mot de la FDJ que vous avez souhaité
de ma part alors
la FDJ et Française des jeux
participent évidemment à la croissance
de ce marché
elle participe d'autant plus que comme
je vous l'ai dit en introduction c'est
l'acteur majeur du secteur
la moitié du chiffre d'affaires du
secteur vient de la FDJ et les
perspectives de croissance qui ont été
affichées publiquement par cette société
sont de l'ordre de trois à quatre pour
cent de croissance annuelle
la FDJ
mobilise tous les outils
numériques qui sont à sa disposition
donc un marketing numérique extrêmement
actif une digitalisation présentée comme
un objectif central de cette société
des activités
y compris des activités traditionnelles
je pense à la loterie qui sont en forte
croissance la loterie dernier semestre
2022 des taux de croissance à deux
chiffres
15%, 20 % de croissance donc
nous avons à la fois une société qui
croit qui croit dans les secteurs
traditionnels qui croient également en
mobilisant toutes les innovations
technologiques qui étant également son
périmètre
d'activités puisque la FDJ a demandé un
agrément en poker
et la FDJ a racheté récemment
ZEturf pardon de manière à pouvoir avoir
une offre également de paris hippiques
donc l'idée et je ne trahis aucun secret
en disant cela de la FDJ c'est de
couvrir l'ensemble de l'offre
et de pouvoir évidemment
avoir une présence tout à fait continue
sur l'ensemble de l'offre présence
continue qui est d'ailleurs assuré par
une stratégie promotionnelle extrêmement
active
qui vise à tout au cours de l'année et
je vais y revenir
comment dire d'avoir une présence
médiatique y compris sur des supports
grand public Télévisions pour assurer
une sorte de fil rouge de cette marque
FDJ tout au long de l'année alors quel
est pour nous
le positionnement du régulateur par
rapport à un acteur dominant enfin un
acteur oui dominant dans le marché qui a
une stratégie de croissance
aussi explicite sachant que cet acteur
dominant est en monopole
nous nous avons j'irai deux
objectifs principaux
premier objectif
maintenir le monopole dans une
croissance modérée
et quand j'utilise ces termes ça n'est
pas les termes du régulateur ce sont les
termes
dans lequel la jurisprudence de la Cour
de justice définit l'action autorisée
des monopoles
qui a été repris par le Conseil d'État
les monopoles sont
quelque part une exception à la libre
prestation de service
les monopoles selon la jurisprudence de
la Cour de justice ne sont autorisés que
lorsqu'il y a des objectifs d'intérêt
général particulier etc mais sous
réserve que leur croissance reste
modérée et que il ne procède pas à une
stimulation active
stimulation active de leurs clients
ça c'est la jurisprudence de la Cour de
justice et encore une fois ça a été
plusieurs reprises confirmée par la
jurisprudence du Conseil d'État donc le
la stratégie enfin le l'objectif du
régulateur c'est de faire en sorte que
la FDJ qui donc un opérateur sous droit
exclusif reste dans ce créneau de
croissance modérée
concrètement à quoi cela conduit-il
cela conduit au moins à deux à deux
actions d'une part sur la publicité
veillez à ce que la publicité que le
monopole propose ne fasse pas sortir la
croissance des clous de la croissance
modérée
or
vous avez probablement observé le fait
que nous avons une stratégie
publicitaire de la FDJ qui comme je vous
l'ai dit consiste à faire en sorte que
cette marque puisse être déclenchée et
présente tout au long de l'année le
vendredi 13 la Saint-Valentin le jour de
Pâques bref tout au fond de l'année et
que par ailleurs
on mobilise à l'appui de cette stratégie
promotionnelle des enjeux d'intérêt
général qui se veulent consensuel
alors c'est le loto du patrimoine pour
partie mais c'est aussi le fait que
la société au nom de sa du développement
durable et de sa responsabilité
sociétale et bien aide le sport aide
l'intégration aide les jeunes et donc
progressivement on accrédite l'idée que
intérêt général
monopole jeux d'argent peuvent aller
strictosensus ensemble et tout ceci
conduit à une forme
peut-être le terme est trop fort mais de
banalisation du jeu d'argent qui est en
tout cas problématique pour le
régulateur donc l'année dernière nous
avions
identifié le problème et nous avions
lors de l'approbation des stratégies
promotionnelles en l'occurrence du
monopole
énergiquement conseillée à la FDJ de
restreindre son activité promotionnelle
de ne pas utiliser les vecteurs les plus
invasifs d'éviter de mobiliser les
enjeux d'intérêt général pour rester
entre guillemets dans les clous de ce
que la jurisprudence autorise et cette
jurisprudence vous le voyez bien elle
est spécifiée comme monopole mais en
réalité elle fait écho à l'obligation
globale qui concerne pour le coup tous
les acteurs du jeu d'argent c'est de
limiter l'offre et la consommation
il faut garder en tête que
la législation sur le jeu d'argent et la
jurisprudence qui va avec c'est toujours
une juris une législation d'exception
là nous avons donc l'année dernière
essayez de faire en sorte que cet acteur
puisse policer
sa activité promotionnelle ça n'a pas
été complètement le cas
et donc
cette année nous avons une nouvelle
occasion qui va nous être donnée dans
l'approbation de la stratégie
promotionnelle 2023 qui est en train de
nous être présenté mais vous voyez bien
que en tout cas c'est un levier par
lequel nous pouvons contraindre entre
guillemets le monopole à rester dans les
clous de ce qui lui est autorisé
juridiquement deuxième levier c'est
évidemment l'encadrement de l'offre de
la FDJ
a des pouvoirs importants puisque nous
autorisons chaque jeu de la FDJ et nous
autorisons le programme des Jeux de la
FDJ programme manuel et à cette occasion
nous avons à plusieurs reprises
demandez à cette société de
redimensionner ces jeux les plus
addictifs je pense à amigo notamment je
pense à bingo life dans lequel on a
essayé de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
moins de tirage des tirages moins
souvent que les jackpot soit un peu
moins importants pour là aussi éviter
que
cette société puisse développer une
offre qui soit une offre trop attractive
et trop présente au bénéfice du public
donc vous voyez que l'actualité de la
FDJ c'est une actualité
délicate pour les régulateurs délicates
pour l'ensemble du secteur puisque nous
avons un très gros qui mobilisent
et on peut on comprend bien pourquoi
dans une logique qui est une logique
très économique qui mobilise tous les
leviers qui sont à sa disposition et
tout ceci doit se faire en respectant
néanmoins le cadre autorisé du monopole
un mot sur le loto biodiversité
mais écoutez monsieur le Président je
crois que vous avez dit l'essentiel
c'est à dire que ce l'autobiodiversité
pour les raisons que je viens d'exposer
concernant la FDJ nous n'étions pas
favorables nous l'avons d'ailleurs
rejeté
c'est un loto qui n'est pas conforme à
la jurisprudence de la Cour de justice
et qui par ailleurs
crée une situation un tout petit peu
curieuse puisque on met en place sur une
thématique qui va attirer les jeunes
puisque la biodiversité le développement
durable ce sont des thèses enfin des
thèmes qui intéressent beaucoup la
jeunesse on met en place une offre qui
va être particulièrement addictif pour
les jeunes donc il nous paraissait que
au-delà de l'aspect juridique il y avait
quand même un problème de positionnement
prescriptique qui était posé et c'est
aussi pour cette raison que nous avons
souhaité le refuser
l'addiction alors l'addiction vous
souhaitez un petit point d'actualité sur
le niveau d'addiction sur les jeux
d'argent et de hasard
la situation
la situation n'est pas la même
que celle qu'on pouvait avoir encore il
y a trois ou quatre ans concernant les
jeux d'argent et de hasard ou il y avait
bien sûr des phénomènes d'addiction mais
ces phénomènes d'addiction restaient
encore
je dirais des phénomènes individuels
des personnes qui tombaient dans
l'addiction là la difficulté que nous
avons c'est que nous avons un écosystème
industriel qui s'est mis en place qui
est très efficace et qui
utilisent toutes les technologies de
captation de l'attention qui sont les
technologies de base de l'économie
numérique pour vendre
et proposer des jeux d'argent au public
donc les études que nous avons sont des
études qui montrent que il y a la
dernière étude de l'OFDT dit qu'il y a
1,4 millions de personnes qui sont
susceptibles d'être joueur problématique
ça correspond à 6 % des joueurs en
général mais on considère que en pari
sportifs c'est plutôt 18% des joueurs de
paris sportifs et là nous avons une
dernière étude qui vient de sortir on a
malheureusement pas la même étude
actualisée que celle de l'OFDT de 2019
nous l'aurons l'année prochaine mais il
y a une étude qui vient de sortir qui
est une étude qui a été faite à partir
d'un panel de joueurs online mais qui
joue à tout type de jeu y compris des
jeux illégaux donc on sait que
l'addiction enfin le taux de prévalence
sur les jeux illégaux les casinos en
ligne etc et beaucoup plus important
mais les taux de prévalence sont des
taux qui sont beaucoup plus proches de
20%
que même de 16 ou de 18%. donc on a un
certain nombre d'indications qui
montrent que les taux de prévalence
augmentent et nous nous avons d'ailleurs
un capteur qui est le fichier des auto
interdits puisque nous gérons maintenant
à la suite du ministère de l'Intérieur
le fichier des auto interdits nous avons
aujourd'hui 80 demandes par jour
d'interdiction d'auto interdiction
volontaire vous savez c'est
l'interdiction vous êtes interdit
pendant trois ans là où on avait
auparavant une vingtaine de dossiers par
jour donc on voit bien que le phénomène
a changé je dirais de dimensions
qui vont vous permettre de rebondir et
de et de traiter d'autres points merci
madame la présidente de cette exposé
très complet
avec
une partie effectivement
nouvelle qui sont les nouvelles
technologies et la façon dont finalement
les jeux sortent de ce qu'on a connu
pour aller vers des technologies
numériques beaucoup plus complexes
l'utilisation des crypto actifs bon etc
vous nous ouvrez des des champs alors on
a pu lire des choses récemment
effectivement sur tel ou telle
entreprise mais
déployer moi ce que je voudrais
avant de passer la parole rapporte en
général pour quelques questions
je voudrais noter je me pose la question
finalement
j'aimerais bien avoir je l'ai un peu on
l'a un peu à travers votre exposé mais
votre ressenti sur finalement
est-ce que
l'autorité que vous présidez
on lui demande pas des choses qui fait
finalement
elles ne sont pas réalisables
c'est-à-dire d'être contraire
de gérer des contraires complets d'une
certaine façon laisser l'économie
se développer et l'économie des jeux
comme comme tout économie d'une façon
puis en même temps vous dire bon comment
dire j'avais noté l'expression que vous
deviez limiter la consommation mais ce
que vous nous dites c'est que
ça marche pas si c'est ça votre objectif
vous nous dites qu'il est pas atteint
excusez-moi de le dire comme ça ou de le
présenter comme ça en tout cas on sent
des des des
volontés un peu qui ne peuvent pas
trouver exactement la réponse et après
c'est
essayer de limiter certaines
consommations mais en même temps même en
faisant des efforts sur la communication
sur etc finalement on se rend compte
qu'il y a une augmentation très forte
malgré tout des paris sportifs par
exemple
voilà est-ce que comment comment
finalement vous jugez est-ce que vous
jugez que vous avez tous les moyens pour
faire quoi et quand vous demande pas une
mission impossible voilà non mais je le
dis en étant très simple quoi mais
en politique on est souvent d'ailleurs
compte on est souvent sur des choses
cette nature on doit trouver des
équilibres entre plusieurs sujets mais
j'ai l'impression que je dirais pas
mission impossible mais rémission plus
que compliquées
vous l'avez déjà évoqué mais que vous y
reveniez ce rapporteur général peut-être
pour répondre d'abord
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Présidente moi je vais être comment
dirais-je un peu dans le droit fil de
de la discussion qu'on avait au monde
pacte je pense qu'on est dans un moment
de folie furieuse alors il y avait le
fameux slogan EMT en même temps et là
c'est tout et son contraire et pour vous
dire ce que je pense je ne comprends pas
cet état qui favorise finalement la
pratique du jeu tout en mettant en place
des dispositif de contrôle vous efforcez
mais on a l'impression que on aura
toujours un train de retard je trouve ça
inquiétant
je trouve ça moralement
je le dis comme je le pense j'ai
répréhensible et vous avez commencé
d'ailleurs votre propos en expliquant
que il y avait une forte progression ça
ne m'avait pas échappé de la pratique
notamment des paris sportifs en ligne en
2021 plus de 40 % d'augmentation
en même temps parce qu'il faut bien le
faire en 2000 à l'automne 2022 santé
publique France lançait une première
campagne de prévention contre les
risques liés aux paris sportifs chez moi
mais j'ai quand même toujours du mal à
comprendre ce même temps
moi je souhaiterais que vous puissiez
nous présenter deux éléments un les
enjeux économiques de ces paris sportifs
en ligne et leur évolution sur les
depuis la loi pacte notamment
sur les montants et puis et puis
peut-être surtout ce qui est conduit par
l'État par ces opérateurs pour
limiter l'addiction j'ai si vous voulez
l'impression qu'on est dans la même
comment dirais ambiguïté vous avez dit
moi j'appelle ça un peu le conflit
d'intérêt vous avez dit il faut éviter
une banalisation c'est à dire c'est
à peu près la même chose que le tabac
quoi
mais c'est vertigineux l'augmentation
des pratiques et donc
des coûts et puis deuxième et dernière
question vous aviez évoqué effectivement
en vous avez pris vos fonctions le fait
que la fiscalité sur les jeux d'argent
et de hasard en France étaient
sensiblement plus forte en France et que
on allait aller vers une harmonisation
européenne pouvez-vous nous dire où on
en est actuellement
puisque nous avons de l'intérêt parmi
nos collègues vous il y a déjà cette
question répondent de façon succincte à
une question à votre aussi
central ça n'est pas si simple que cela
il est évident que le cadre légal des
jeux d'argent crée
en soi-même des tensions et le rôle du
régulateur et de rester sur la ligne de
crête et de faire en sorte que ce qui
est par principe interdit peut par
dérogation être autorisé c'est ça je
dirais le cœur du cadre non mais c'est
le principe et ça n'est autorisé qu'à
une condition c'est que le jeu d'argent
reste récréatif le pacte social
collectif qui a été formé dans ce cadre
légal par ce cadre légal c'est de dire
donc font le jeu d'argent est toléré et
ça ça existe je dirais de longue date à
condition qu'il reste récréatif
aujourd'hui on voit que cette notion de
jeu récréatif c'est une notion qui est
quand même fragilisée par les pratiques
parce que cet écosystème industriel qui
s'est mis en place effectivement
attendant sa industrialiser le jeu
d'argent et de à le rendre de moins en
moins récréatif est-ce que pour autant
c'est impossible de garder cet équilibre
moi je ne le crois pas je crois que
d'ailleurs dans tous les pays on est
confronté à la même situation la France
d'ailleurs n'est pas le pays qui est le
plus en difficulté sur ces enjeux
pourquoi parce que des pays comme la
Grande-Bretagne qui ont libéralisé
beaucoup plus que nous se trouvent
confronté à un retour de situation
catastrophique d'un certain nombre de
joueurs d'opinions publiques extrêmement
négatifs sur le jeu d'argent alors que
nous nous avons eu une croissance qui
était beaucoup plus
contrôlée du jeu d'argent donc ma
réponse elle en deux terres en deux
temps un le régulateur
doit mobiliser tous les outils qui sont
les siens et nous avons je crois fait
cet exercice
et on pourra le démontrer en 2023 et 2
il faudra se livrer et c'est l'objectif
que nous avons à partir du mois de mai à
un bilan critique de la régulation en se
disant est-ce que dans le fond ces
outils d'intervention sont suffisants ou
est-ce qu'il faut par exemple sur la
publicité donner les moyens aux
régulateur de plafonner les budgets
marketing ce qui n'est pas le cas avoir
la possibilité de restreindre les
horaires de diffusion de la publicité
limiter la publicité des jeux d'argent à
certains supports qui sont des supports
professionnels mais pas les supports
grand public il y a toute une série
d'idées qui nous viennent d'ailleurs de
nos homologues que nous pourrions tout à
fait pratiquer en France pour faire en
sorte que ce jeu d'argent reste dans ce
son épure récréative alors
les paris sportifs effectivement les
paris sportifs se sont énormément
développés dans les années passées les
chiffres sur 2022 sont des chiffres qui
sont un tout petit peu qui ont l'air de
montrer une tendance un tout petit peu
différente
avec le sentiment que nous avons d'un
ralentissement
de la croissance des paris sportifs on a
le sentiment que nous atteignons un
plateau et que finalement les taux de
croissance que nous avions connus
précédemment ne se reproduiront pas
est-ce que c'est quelque chose une
tendance de long terme je n'en sais rien
mais en tout cas c'est ce que nous
observons sur 2022 et sur les paris
sportifs effectivement c'est la première
fois que il y a eu ses campagnes grand
public de santé publique France de la NJ
du département de la Seine-Saint-Denis
et ce sont des campagnes qui ont très
bien fonctionné par exemple la campagne
de l'Anji tu as vu tu as perdu tu as vu
tu as perdu pardonnez-moi l'expression
c'est une campagne qui a fait presque 2
millions d'euros deux millions de vues
sur Youtube et qui a été reprise par
toute une série de supports donc
quand on adapte le message on est
capable d'aller chercher le joueur là où
il est et ça fonctionne plutôt bien
merci
peut-être je me demande si c'est pas une
deuxième question du rapporteur général
sur la fiscalité
et bien
la situation n'a pas tellement changé
par rapport à 2020 pourquoi parce que ça
n'est pas une zone d'harmonisation et
que chaque pays est bien soucieux de
garder sa fiscalité propre donc
effectivement on a un taux de
prélèvement tout acteur confondu qui est
de l'ordre de 50% en France là où les
autres pays européens sont plutôt autour
de 20 à 25 et donc il y a aussi une
concurrence entre acteurs européens
entre pays européens en termes
d'attractivité des jeux d'argent et un
pays comme Malte par exemple est un pays
qui évidemment offre une fiscalité des
jeux qui est particulièrement
intéressante et il y a beaucoup
d'entreprises qui sont installées à
Malte nous sur les 17 opérateurs en
concurrence on en a cinq qui sont
localisés à Malte
merci
donc Emmanuel Capu puis Jean-Michel
Arnaud
merci monsieur le Président
et merci madame la Présidente pour ses
explications extrêmement détaillées et
pointu alors moi je veux pas rentrer
dans le
débattre trop trop politique la question
que je voudrais poser c'est une question
de sénateur de d'attaché au territoire
comme nous sommes tous et il y a une
question qu'on a assez peu du coup
abordé sous ce prisme là c'est celle du
PMU vous avez cité le PMU vous avez cité
le progestable donc le
la modernisation je dirais l'adaptation
du PMU aux nouvelles formes de jeu
en revanche je crois que nous sommes
plusieurs sans doute plus encore quand
on a aussi des filières d'élevage à être
attachés à notre réseau de PMU pour deux
raisons la première c'est parce que ça a
créé un réseau de vie sociale c'est
aussi le bon côté quand même de de de ce
type de jeu une politique sociale utile
dans notre irrigue nos territoires il y
a une deuxième raison c'est que le PME a
une vocation particulière c'est de
financer la filière équine donc je mets
je dirais le PME un peu à part par
rapport à tous les autres jeux dont on a
beaucoup parlé et donc ma question est
très simple c'est quel est l'état du du
PMU du de ce réseau par et de cette
société par rapport aux autres vous avez
dit que le FDJ s'apprêtait 50% du marché
mais quelle est la part de marché du PMU
quel est son état comment
s'adapte-t-elle à l'évolution à
l'ouverture donc des jeux en ligne
depuis un certain temps
et quel est l'avenir peut-être de ces
réseaux qui qui aussi irriguent nos
territoires c'est donc les points de
vente en fait très clairement merci
beaucoup merci Emmanuel Jean-Michel
larnault puis Jean-Pierre Vaugel merci
monsieur le Président merci Madame
présidente de votre présentation
complète et
ampli de paradoxe
de ce que je retiens également
l'intervention du rapporteur général
finalement faisant lui-même allusion à
la politique sur le tabac
le sujet qui est le nôtre et de savoir
si on le privilégier la santé publique
aux intérêts de groupes privés moi je
qualifie pour partie d'entre eux de
prédateurs
avez-vous dans ces cadres là
aujourd'hui les outils le cadre
juridique dans le cadre de vos missions
d'autorité nationale des jeux pour par
exemple
mettre en place un moratoire sur
l'autorisation de nouveaux jeux pour
faciliter la meilleure communication à
destination du grand public des niveaux
de rendement réels des jeux d'argent au
cas des souscrivent de pour exemple
faire en sorte aussi
que les mineurs qui sont 40% à peu près
d'après les informations recueillies des
parieurs généraux
puissent effectivement être protégé
puisqu'il y a une interdiction qui n'est
pas respectée
et cela me semble effectivement un
élément important et puis aussi agir par
exemple sur la réduction pour pas dire
l'annulation l'interdiction des offres
de bienvenue qui sont effectivement une
façon de favoriser de mettre en
addiction des jeunes gens qui n'ont pas
pour le premier pari à mettre ne
serait-ce qu'un euro sur la table mais
ensuite se retrouve dans des logiques
effectivement d'addiction liées à des
problématiques de santé psychique
mentales d'addiction donc avez-vous les
outils et les instruments aujourd'hui
les quatre juridiques pour agir dans ce
cadre là sinon quels sont vos
propositions je vous remercie merci
Jean-Michel Jean-Pierre Vaugel puis
philippe Dominati et merci monsieur le
Président merci madame la Présidente moi
je voulais l'intervenir comme mon
collègue capuche sur problématique du
GIE PMU parce qu'il faut rappeler que le
PMU qui est un des principaux opérateurs
aussi constitués sous forme juridique de
GIE et que la totalité de ces excédents
sont reversés à la filière aux sociétés
mères et que sans le PMU on n'aurait pas
eu le Prix d'Amérique on n'aurait pas
les courses on n'aurait pas les 200
hippodromes donc vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure on n'aurait pas les dizaines de
milliers d'emplois qu'il y a et toutes
les activités annexes et que c'est
complètement différent de la FDJ et
quand dans vos propos j'ai pas compté le
nombre de fois où vous avez prononcé FDJ
et le nombre de fois que vous avez
prononcé PMU mais à mon avis le PMU est
beaucoup plus important que que la FDJ
et à ce titre là j'aimerais savoir s'il
y a des actions que la NJ engage pour
essayer de
bien maîtriser la distorsion de
l'occurrence qu'il peut y avoir entre la
FDJ et le PMU je pense qu'on a une
véritable distorsion de concurrence
d'ailleurs vous avez bien indiqué que
c'est un acteur dominant la FDJ est un
acteur dominant sur les jeux d'argent
qu'ils viennent de racheter 7 heures qui
est un opérateur qui représente 20 % des
paris online des paris hippiques online
et que ça pourrait éventuellement
représenter un danger pour pour le PMU
donc j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur y
a-t-il une distorsion de concurrence
entre les moyens que je qualifierais de
disproportionnée de la FDJ pour assurer
sa promotion par rapport au PMU et
est-ce qu'il y a un risque de survie du
PMU dans ce cadre-là et de l'ensemble de
la filière équine
merci Jean-Pierre philippe Dominati puis
Didier Rambo
merci pour le
sérieux et la passion que vous mettez
dans la défense de votre institution
mais je partage un peu des avis qui ont
été
formulés précédemment parce que on n'est
pas dans une situation schizophrène on
se demande si la Haute autorité n'est
pas un alibi la Française des Jeux a été
vendue par l'État tout simplement alors
vous nous expliquer maintenant que c'est
plus l'état qui la contrôle elle va
beaucoup mieux elle se développe il y a
une croissance donc à croire que lorsque
l'état gère quelque chose il arrive pas
bien de gérer mais s'il le vend c'est
pour le valoriser donc est-ce que ça a
été une bonne chose une mauvaise chose
et est-ce que ce n'est pas
contradictoire parce que ce qu'on vend
pas une propriété pour finalement après
immédiatement la valeur empêcher son
activité par des contraintes c'est ce
que je comprends pas et deuxièmement
vous avez évoqué juste titre
les vignettes sont rares hier un article
dans les échos capitalisation 4
milliards de francs ils sont passés 260
euros pardon de
270 millions d'euros en 2021 500
millions en 2022 3 millions
d'utilisateurs c'est une licorne
française
on peut se demander si elle était
anglaise ou je dirais étrangère
l'activité serait exactement la même
vous l'avez souillé vous souligné il n'y
a pas de coordination européenne et ce
qu'il vaut mieux pas que il y ait ce
genre d'activité sur notre territoire
national puisque de toute façon les
utilisateurs seraient de toute manière
partie je dirais dans le marché européen
ailleurs donc il y a une activité là
aussi qui est faite effectivement on a
du mal à comprendre si l'État n'a pas
intérêt en réalité avoir des recettes
importantes par la fiscalité en
développant ou en laissant faire ce
genre
je dirais d'initiative et que la Haute
Autorité est là que pour donner je
dirais une sorte de de garantie à peu
près morale ou en tout cas faire
semblant de faire quelque chose parce
que on voit que ça se ça se développe et
que l'État a favorisé largement le
développement
voyez madame que les questions sont
directes au moins
Didier
madame la Présidente souhaitez-vous
interpeler plus précisément sur la
régulation des des du marché des casinos
en ligne puisque je l'avais été lors de
l'examen du dernier PLF bon a priori la
France et le dernier pays d'Europe
en interdire la pratique et là on
constate que l'oeuf une offre
pléthorique de casino en ligne et
notamment en France il y a j'avais deux
chiffres il y a moins de 10 ans et on
avait à peu près 500 000 joueurs
aujourd'hui on en aurait pratiquement
pas loin de 2 millions de 2 millions
d'euros donc on voit derrière aussi les
les enjeux financiers je crois que ça
représente à peu près plus de plus d'un
milliard d'euros donc on imagine bien
les centaines de millions d'euros de
recettes fiscales qui sont perdus par
l'État une question toute simple pour la
comment on peut arriver aussi à réguler
un petit peu ce sujet de des casinos en
ligne merci merci
Daniel Brouilly puis Bernard delcro
merci merci madame la Présidente de
votre exposé très complet j'étais il y a
trois jours à l'hôpital Paul Brousse
dans ma circonscription qui a un service
d'addictologie et j'ai été
effrayé oui de constater que désormais
l'addiction au jeu et
aux outils numériques et devenu une des
principales addictions et que ça
représente à peu près un quart de leur
entre 20% et un quart des consultations
et évidemment avec un public jeune
extrêmement marqué donc je vais me poser
une question d'abord a-t-on une analyse
sociologique par âge et par catégorie
sociale des jeux et des montants parce
que j'ai quand même l'impression qu'au
fond plus le sentiment de crise de mal
vie grandit et plus l'addiction au jeu 7
ans et puis la deuxième c'était presque
en forme de provocation est-ce qu'il
faudra pas créer un de l'hôpital pour
financer les services d'addictologie qui
auront à prendre en charge de plus en
plus je pense notamment aux jeunes en
tous les cas il y a pour moi un sujet
très important direction de la jeunesse
et ce que vous avez exposé que
j'ignorais en tous les cas en partie
renforce franchement une inquiétude et
je pense ça devrait devenir un sujet
hier vous avez présenté un texte pour
que eau à minimal les gens sachent quels
sont les frais qu'ils encourent par les
banques etc je enfin vous faites
d'ailleurs des publicités pour montrer
que au fond dans le jeu on ne gagne pas
on ne gagne pas à chaque fois mais moi
je vous avoue que je suis très inquiète
ce que j'ai vu il y a quelques jours et
de la façon dont des vies sont malmenées
par cette addiction au jeu des vies et
des familles parce que les jeunes qui
étaient là qu'on a pu rencontrer son
sont pas très à l'aise mais derrière il
y a aussi des familles qui sont mises à
mal par ces addictions nouvelles voilà
donc merci Daniel on retient le loto de
l'hôpital
dans les nouvelles idées
Bernard delcro oui merci monsieur le
Président merci Madame pour cette exposé
très très complet et très intéressant
alors moi j'avais des questions sur
l'addiction moi ça m'a été posées par
par des collègues mais
je voudrais quand même appuyer ce qui a
été dit avez-vous des des éléments sur
les catégories sociales les plus
touchées par cette question d'addiction
ça voudrait aussi vous avez parlé de la
Vendée qui est beaucoup de croissance
dans dans
les jeux
même chose est-ce qu'on a des éléments
sur les catégories qui sont voilà les
les plus empreintes à cela et puis sur
cette croissance il y a une émergence
évidemment liée aux innovations
technologiques les jeux en ligne etc et
tout cette émergence ces dernières
années est-ce que ça se fait au
détriment des circuits classiques ou
est-ce qu'il y a de la croissance dans
tous les domaines et encore voilà
attendez éléments sur les catégories les
plus touchées par
cette par cette cette croissance et puis
voilà j'avais une question sur les
comparaisons de fiscalité avec les
autres pays mais elle a été posée par le
rapporteur général et vous y avez
répondu voilà merci beaucoup
merci Bernard madame la Présidente
merci
alors je vais commencer par le PMU
si j'ai beaucoup parlé de la FDJ c'est
parce que il n'y avait pas de question
dans votre questionnaire sur le PMU
en revanche le PMU est clairement
un objet de fort intérêt pour nous
donc le PMU représente un peu moins de
20% du PBJ le PMU avait fortement
souffert pendant la crise du covid et
grâce à différentes mesures internes
qu'ils ont prises il a retrouvé entre
guillemets une bonne santé économique et
le résultat net du PMU est un résultat
net qui est comparable cette année à ce
qu'il était en 2019 et donc
effectivement c'est ce résultat net qui
alimente toute la filière équine et
croyez bien que nous avons très
clairement en tête la nécessité de
garantir et d'aider à la stabilité de ce
revenu pour la filière Reiki et nous
avons d'ailleurs très clairement dit
ceci à l'Autorité de la concurrence à
l'occasion du de l'opération auteurs
puisque nous allons être consultés par
l'Autorité de la concurrence et que
l'analyse de marché
c'est en fait les chiffres de la NJ qui
seront donnés à l'Autorité de la
concurrence donc il est évident que pour
nous
l'opération enfin la répartition des
acteurs sur le pari hippique ne doit pas
ou du moins on doit être très vigilant
sur l'équilibre des filières dans le
cadre des variations que les parts de
concurrence peuvent avoir donc
voilà c'est c'est en tout cas le PMU est
revenu à une bonne santé et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le PMU comme la
FDJ a retrouvé une activité très
positive sur ces points de vente
donc en réalité le segment en ligne du
pari hippique qui s'était énormément
développé l'année dernière maintenant le
moteur entre guillemets du PMU c'est le
pari hippique en dur
alors
est-ce que vous avez dans le fond le
cadre juridique pour agir
c'est un peu en filigrane derrière un
certain nombre de questions
je réponds d'abord à des questions
spécifiques avant de parler de la
problématique générale concernant
l'offre je l'ai mentionné l'offre nous
avons la possibilité de cantonner
l'offre et nous avons par exemple
demander à la FDJ de limiter sa gamme de
jeu de grattage à 5 euros nous l'avons
plafonné pas de création autorisée de
nouveaux jeux à 5 euros donc on a la
possibilité via l'encarne le programme
des Jeux de la FDJ de cantonner l'offre
et nous sommes en train de réfléchir
puisque les offres addictives ne
concernent pas exclusivement l'offre de
loterie mais elle peut concerner aussi
par exemple le poker on a des nouvelles
formules de poker qui s'appelle par
exemple expresso ce sont des pockets des
tournois de poker qui dure 5 minutes
et ça ce sont des tournois extrêmement
addictifs parce que finalement la
barrière à l'entrée pour un joueur est
très faible et ça va très vite là aussi
on est en train de réfléchir à la
possibilité que nous avons d'encadrer
ces offres en particulier de poker donc
encadrement de l'offre
2 essayez de travailler à ce que
j'appellerai la vérité des prix
la vérité des prix ça veut dire
déconstruire tous les messages
des opérateurs de jeux d'argent qui
mettent en avant évidemment les jackpot
la possibilité d'avoir un retour
important pour le joueur mais qui en
réalité ne donne pas aux joueurs la
transparence exacte de son activité de
jeu et on dit aux joueurs par exemple
vous avez gagné alors qu'en réalité il a
simplement remboursé sa mise donc pour
favoriser la vérité des prix nous sommes
en train de travailler à la mise en
place d'une sorte de tableau de bord
une sorte de compteur qui permettrait à
chaque joueur de savoir exactement ce
qu'il a dépensé et ce qu'il a
effectivement gagné
les mineurs c'est un problème majeur les
mineurs c'est un problème majeur il joue
dans les points de vente il joue en
ligne contrairement à tout ce qui est
dit
le contrôle des points de vente et le
contrôle du jeu des mineurs en ligne
n'est pas suffisant nous avons
considérablement renforcer notre
pression auprès des opérateurs PMU et
FDJ pour que ceci accentue leur contrôle
sur les points de vente et concernant
les activités de jeux en ligne nous
avons toute une série d'éléments que
nous allons d'ailleurs
sur lequel nous allons réinsister à
l'occasion de l'approbation des
stratégies promotionnelles et des plans
d'action annuels addiction pour faire en
sorte que il n'y ait pas par exemple de
stratégie de contournement de
l'interdiction de l'offre à des mineurs
en ligne donc ça c'est un enjeu majeur
de l'activité de contrôle de la NJ en
2023 sur les bonus
sur les bonus nous avons publié des
guidelines des lignes directrices en
octobre dernier qui vise à notamment
plafonner les bonus de bienvenue parce
que les bonus de bienvenue c'est
l'extension du périmètre des joueurs et
donc nous avons demandé qu'il soit
plafonné à 100 euros auparavant nous
avions des bonus de bienvenue qui
étaient de 400 350 euros 100 euros
maximum à demander la engie pendant le
mondial de foot c'est une limite une
contrainte qui a été globalement
respectée et on n'a pas eu de bonus de
bienvenue à la hauteur de ce qui avait
été pratiqué précédemment pendant l'Euro
donc ça fonctionne
est-ce que
pour autant la NJ est un alibi le mot
est fort
le mot est fort la NJ exerce ses
compétences dans le respect du cadre
juridique qui lui est donné par la loi
donc par les parlementaires
donc nous avons je l'ai bien dit
mobiliser tous les outils qui sont les
nôtres
nous allons avoir un bilan critique de
la régulation au mois de mai et le cas
échéant nous ferons des propositions
complémentaires pour que le cadre
juridique puisse être ici ou là complété
de manière à donner plus de capacités
d'action ou régulateur et je crois
effectivement que c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire en termes d'effectif mais
c'est aussi nécessaire en termes de
capacité d'intervention je vous donne un
exemple moi je n'ai pas la capacité de
mettre en demeure
un opérateur la mise en demeure d'un
opérateur c'est une disposition qui
existe auprès d'autres autorités de
régulation qui est extrêmement efficace
facilement mobilisable qui permet
également d'avoir une action publique
immédiate c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas dans le cadre de la loi
donc on a toute une série entre
guillemets d'idées qui permettent
effectivement de compléter et de voir si
l'action du régulateur pour encadrer un
marché qui est en pleine transformation
est effectivement nécessaire je crois
que ça l'est mais il faut faire des
propositions de façon je dirais vraiment
informé
Sora
concernant Sora
nous avons
accepté la proposition de Sora qui donc
était potentiellement en situation en
situation de manquement par rapport à
notre cadre juridique on a accepté sa
proposition de mettre en place une
loterie à double entrée concrètement
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une loterie à
double entrée c'est une loterie dans
lequel le canal payant qui est le canal
actuel et le canal gratuit
bénéficie des mêmes chances de gagner
ils ont jusqu'au 31 mars pour mettre en
place ce dispositif si au 31 mars
c'est-à-dire dans un mois et demi le
dispositif n'est pas pleinement
opérationnel et totalement convaincant
et bien nous reviendrons à la situation
initiale c'est-à-dire une entreprise
potentiellement en situation de
manquement
Sora effectivement ouvre des franchises
dans un certain nombre de pays
il n'y a pas d'harmonisation totale au
niveau européen en revanche ne nous
parlons entre autorité de régulation en
particulier
la yu-gi-bling la l'autorité
britannique et les Suisses donc nous
essayons de faire en sorte que les
positions des uns et des autres soient à
peu près coordonnées donc nous allons
voir ce qui se passe
mais en tout cas
comment dire l'histoire saura n'est pas
totalement terminée en France ce que je
veux quand même mentionner c'est que
nous avons le gouvernement a demandé à
l'Inspection générale des finances une
étude pour réfléchir à l'évolution du
cadre juridique
les propositions qui doivent être faites
d'ici elles doivent être faites d'ici la
fin du mois
sont des propositions qui
on ne sait pas encore la proposition
définitive mais en tout cas il y en a
une partie d'entre elles qui viserait à
extraire sera
du champ des jeux d'argent
et à mettre en place une régulation
allégée au bénéfice de cette société
nous nous sommes tout à fait opposés à
cette proposition qui comporte des
effets de bord
par rapport à la régulation classique
extrêmement importante et je crois non
mesurer à ce stade et qui aurait pour
conséquence de déconstruire pour partie
l'édifice institutionnel qu'on a mis en
place depuis 2010
les casinos en ligne je terminerai par
ceci
c'est vrai que nous sommes dans une
situation atypique en France France et
Chypre sont les seuls à ne pas autoriser
les casinos
nous avons et nous avons lancé une étude
qui est une étude c'est la première
étude qui est vraiment
sérieuse et indépendante des acteurs
économiques sur
l'offre illégale en France
nous avons sollicité KPMG nous aurons
les résultats de cette étude permettant
de savoir exactement ce que représente
vraiment l'offre illégale en France et
vous savez que l'offre illégale en
France elle est largement composée de
l'offre de casino
à ce stade ce que je peux dire c'est que
l'offre de casino est une casino online
c'est une offre dont les caractères
addictifs sont documentés donc la
régulation si elle devait autoriser
cette offre devrait nécessairement
prévoir des garanties supérieures sur
la protection du joueur et que par
ailleurs nous avons en France une
situation qui est atypique par rapport
aux autres pays puisque nous avons un
réseau de casino qui irriguent entre
guillemets le territoire et d'après les
premiers calculs que nous avons fait si
une offre de casino online devait être
autorisé en France
[Musique]
ça conduirait probablement à une perte
de 30% des casinos physiques
donc ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
toute une série de paramètres et
économique juridique
état du soin qui doivent être prises en
compte avant de prendre une décision de
cette ampleur
écouter je crois que j'ai répondu
alors sur l'addiction pardonnez-moi
est-ce que vous avez des chiffres précis
sur l'addiction on sait que l'addiction
touche en particulier les jeunes en
particulier les catégories populaires
les publics vulnérables et que donc ils
sont je dirais doublement
affecté par le jeu d'argent ils perdent
de l'argent et on a eu des cas mais
j'imagine que les uns les autres vous
les avez eus de situations absolument
dramatique de personnes sans détente
sans des temps y compris auprès entre
guillemets de la criminalité organisée
enfin je veux dire il y a toute une
série de phénomènes qui montrent que
c'est
une situation qui n'est pas du tout
anecdotique et qui doit être traitée
très sérieusement
ce que je peux dire c'est que nous nous
pensons que la première couche de
prévention c'est à dire la couche
d'information générale
santé publique n'est pas suffisamment
active et que
[Musique]
ça dépasse le périmètre de la engie mais
que il faudrait absolument
déjà
renforcer cette sensibilisation aux jeux
d'argent et à la prévention des risques
sur le jeu d'argent nous avons info
joueur Info Service pardon qui est un
dispositif
comment dire de premier niveau qui je
crois pourrait être
améliorer en matière de jeux d'argent et
de hasard
j'ai répondu
très bien merci madame la Présidente
était ravie de vous revoir parce que
deux ans donc c'est deux ans et demi
c'est bien pour avoir un premier état
des lieux vos premières remarques merci
vous êtes exprimé aussi très franchement
ça n'est pas moi enfin très clairement
sur à la fois
ce qui vous paraît bien fonctionné à la
fois de ce qui est possiblement
améliorable voilà sur une mission dont
on continue à partager je pense tous
être un peu complexe plus que d'autres
voilà merci beaucoup bonne journée chers
collègues